abbiamo un aneddoto che vale ci
racconterà legato all'estate
ok mio bari quindi mio fratello capire
no dai non si può ma lo faremo più
avanti non vuoi davvero raccontare
si si non mi interessa non è silvia
questa volta è proprio valentino è
peggio per gabri non per me ciao ragazzi
bentornati a una nuova puntata da vita
buttata a summer edition il tema della
puntata di oggi e disastri estivi si sa
che l'estate è quel periodo dell'anno
nel quale la maggior parte delle persone
e fa cose incontra persone vive
esperienze che poi dimentica non appena
si allontana dalla spiaggia e più delle
volte perché fa molto comodo
dimenticarle ed è per questo che oggi
vorrei fare per una chiacchiera su
quelle che sono state le cose più
assurde che mi sono successe durante
l'estate per fare questa chiacchieravano
bisogno una persona con la quale negli
ultimi anni ho spesso condiviso una
parte delle mie vacanze ecco perché ho
l'onore di presentarvi all'interno degli
studios di casa mia la mia amica
valentina salve con un ora da 3 anni 4
anni forse saltandole uno che ci
facciamo almeno una settimana dieci
giorni ormai di vacanza insieme nero
cioè io vado a scrocco al caso si adatta
o ed è l'unico motivo per cui siamo
amici ma infatti l'anno in cui non siamo
andati i nomi è calcolata di perni sono
stati amici ti sei dimenticato della mia
esistenza
fermi invece quest'anno che anche il suo
compleanno che ho fatto il regalo
addirittura si non me lo ricordo
talmente con dovendo a scroccare
altrimenti guarda stai tranquilla che
guglielmo non esiste essere brutto
essere concentrici essere nate ad agosto
come la maggior parte dei leoni droga è
proprio al mese sbagliato per farci in
assolutamente sì comunque partiamo
subito ad ascoltare il messaggio che ci
sono i fatti ero in un villaggio
turistico calabria è levata amicizia con
un animatore con cui andava a
rimorchiare la sila una serie in
particolare o e animatore scompare vero
indefinite pure tipo 5 6 7 ore all'alba
lo ritrovo a gand
portare in ospedale perché aveva passato
letteralmente una notte di fuoco che
hanno dovuto fare una flebo che aveva un
nome russo gigantesco una cosa
spaventosa maestro genere perché ogni
volta che io queste cose le date e non
lo so vale attiri evidente delle energie
una delle esperienze che ricordo più
divertenti dell'estate quella che
abbiamo passato io e altri miei amici
quando ancora eravamo tutti scapoli
allineano siamo riattivati camente primo
giorno abbiamo fatti a scorta e
superalcolici nella speranza di trovare
magari qualche ragazzo con il quale
condividere le cose che ovviamente poi
non è capitata e quindi ci siamo
ritrovati in quanto deve finire una 30
35 bottiglie di superalcolici che
abbiamo seguito con il gioco del drago
ci siamo svegliati il giorno dopo io
personalmente in un mare di uomini sotto
il lavandino del bagno una beige
sabbiato un unico completamente nudo
solo due calzini successo in un altro
nemico invece che aveva spalmato di
buoni tolto ad albergo nè tipo una notte
da leoni e da poveri ragazzi ma stiamo
scherzando una gamma che il gioco del
drago che cosa fa esattamente
prima di tutto bisogna bere
responsabilmente ragazzi cioè basta
queste cose bisogna per forza un
piegarsi per divertirsi e io sono bene o
per chi guardi me ma sicuramente vale a
questa cosa che è molto stemmi aroma di
vita faceva intento di conifera fa
logica pellicole si tuffa su uno scivolo
pericolosissimo anche settimane ci credo
non ci credo
fate sapere a valentina qual è questo
parco ecco signorina dovrebbe una dimora
[Risate]
e così abbiamo riportato busca la
mascherina e non riuscivo a respirare la
mancanza in sicilia paio di amici con un
cartone di vino bianco caldo stavano
bevendo un nostro amico ha deciso di
andare a fare la pipì deciso di parlare
di un bicchiere essendo anche il vino
caldo ha buttato via il bicchiere di
vino e ha continuato bene e per questo
che non si beve ragazzi e per questo ho
detto delle cose molto forti simile a
questa nella vita buttata insieme a
claudio sulle brega tour è ok mi scappa
pv e se mi alzo è finita mi rubano gioco
della scorsa sono riempito di nuovo la
birra ma non siamo qui per parlare di
questo bevete responsabilmente non la
vostra vino la persona esempio siamo
beccati dai nostri genitori tutti
ubriachi mio padre mi ha beccato mentre
stavo levando dei pomodori in testa una
ragazza perché è un'altra ragazza mi 30
st dio pensano i miei capelli manco di
trovare basta una grande lezione della
vita ragazzi masticate cioè ti prego
cioè che schifo avevo 9 anni mi sono
buttata a bomba nella piscina dei
bambini che sarà mezzo metro di acqua
niente mi sono rotto una caviglia però
prima di andare all'ospedale perché ho
letto i miei che lui mi ero fatta male
mi sono fatta a fare la mia mamma la
frangetta e capelli possono andare in
ospedale
stavo malissimo metti che ha 9 anni
incontri derek shepard all'ospedale devi
essere pronta ma restiamo derek shepherd
brescia in parterre ferragosto
mi ero appena mollato con una ragazza
dopo una relazione
sei anni dirige ne fanno un break area
di buttare a mare mi ha dubbi nel
portafoglio di lasciano senza vestiti
est oppure per affogare
non contento non sapevo come tornare a
casa
mutande con dovuto chiamare la mamma ma
è una storia terribile sta rivalutando
la nostra amicizia dopo questo forse
siamo davvero amici si fanno queste
palle alte che mi ha dato un'idea per
queste solo noi non sono tutto non si
provare per loro spiega mamma cara
valentina si è allontanata da sola e
l'ho detto di non farlo preparato a
dirle ma ti prego ti prego vale mi mette
in difficoltà non l'ho trovato ha
chiamato chiunque qualsiasi persona
valentina non si trovava però se che è
successa al contrario quando tu sei
andato con il cavolo di cai schio
mamma mia io mi sono sentita neville
paciock che pensa o mio dio ucciso harry
potter permetto eri morto e non sapevo
come tornare a casa e dire a mia madre
non come convivere per il resto la toni
da con questa colpa io vedevo questa
bella vela e improvvisamente il vuoto
non c'era più niente io inizio a nuotare
per andargli incontro quando una
famiglia di grazie inizia a parlare con
un inglese malgara anche l'enea uso
campo l'inglese vale l'estate scorsa mi
sono seduta su una poverina ho il
terrore anche se in realtà alle api non
sono cattive sicuro che non fosse una
vespa prima di arrivare al grande
aneddoto choc
c'è anche un altro aneddoto che vorrei
raccontare di una vacanza che avevo
fatto a ponza che è stato un regalo
stupendo io non c'ero no no no io non
c'è stato un regalo come hai fatto tu
insieme ad altri miei carissimi amici
per il compleanno
andiamo a ponza incominciamo a torturare
valentina io e il mio mi con raffaele
facendole tipo degli scatti fotografici
quell'estate all'estate nella quale non
so perché abbia iniziato a photoshop
arti le tette
ho avuto solo maniaci che mi hanno
seguita vero 2000 dovremo metterli alla
fine del video tipo una notte da leoni
bisognerebbe di trovarle per farle e no
è impossibile bruciate tutte siamo su
una salita ripidissima impressionante
c'è una cosa che non ha mai visto è un
grande evento isolato e se c'è del nodo
di no iniziava allentare in salita
accesi nel generale centa scendi via
crociano che io vendo velocità e turchi
e ti butti sopra vediamo se riusciamo da
tifosa meno vicine scende inizia a
prendere velocità proseguo la il
percorso senza fermarvi gennaro rimane
abbastanza dietro al buio tornando
indietro vede gennaro nascosto con una
faccia abbiamo l'immagine a gennaio e
gina giani di suo a dicembre
l'immagine accennare ai bus 38 s c'è una
fascia bianca cade mente attaccato poco
sotto maurizio che scherzava dal capo a
madrid dove lasciatelo pane un taglio
sulla me è il caso ne ferisce la figlia
ma decido poverina
solo sulla montagna un like ragazzi per
gennaro perché nella vita almeno una
volta nella vita
siamo tutti stati gennaro soldi donati
dimenticati
lo capisco gennaro voglio bene fratello
ciao
una sera quando avevo 16 17 anni sono
tornata a casa ubriachi si ma è un
giardino e ho paura di entrare in casa e
a fare la cacca dentro casa perché non
sentisse lo sciacquone si svegliasse e
cominciasse a parlarmi perché non era
assolutamente in grado di parlare e
quindi ho deciso di pagare vicino alla
sua macchina soddisfattissima superbello
proprio sopra centro la borsa l'ha
tirata sulla buttata dentro un cespuglio
non è stata anche grazie che pensiero
dolce e delicato ma il tuo commento mi
fa ragionare su una cosa è arrivato il
momento si collega laniera perfetta alla
chiusura di questo video all'aneddoto di
valentina e di mio fratello gabriele
prende un bel respiro dai condividi con
noi la tua storia
la mia storia inizia l'estate scorsa era
già un'estate difficile ma il mio
migliore amico ha deciso di invitarmi a
casa sua in sicilia insieme a tutta la
sua famiglia
un atto proprio di cuore generoso
generoso mi porta in questa località
amena a notare inizia a fare la
sirenetta noto fatti affronta mi
allontano un certo punto gabriele tuo
fratello lo saluto con la mano lui mi
dice anche come noti bene valentina e
lui si allontana medico fa bene si vorrà
fare
vuoi io continuo a notare fillers and
mary land ignara di tutto a sera a cena
il mantova contro la delicatezza di
raccontarvela che poi mi sono fatta una
doccia di quattro è proprio la spugna
quella per i piatti cosa ti racconta
valentina gabriele eravamo andati a
mangiare pesce crudo e questo gli aveva
smosso qualcosa nell'intestino non
sapeva come espletare i suoi bisogni che
ha deciso di farlo di mare aggiungo un
altro piccolo del taglio che a quel
punto gabriele che aveva la maschera
inizia a guardare analizzare la
consistenza frastagliata della sua opera
che uscita a detta sua con uno spruzzo
di seppia questi pesciolini che vanno
tutti quanti lì a cercare di cibarsi e
lui con la mano inizia a fare un
mulinello rivede questi colori che
iniziano a vorticare pesci e materiale
organico di altra natura e lui si
immaginava la musica di fantasia 2000 a
quel punto di non fa in tempo a girarsi
mentre sta lì a vorticare un mulinello
di mer che vedeva
finale valentina va a unirsi insieme a
tutti i pesci non sentivo la musica di
sottofondo
io devo andare alla marmi ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla fine di questo video vale
grazie mille per il tuo coraggio
veramente si formerà i film silla da
zero gratello a richiamo di fargli
mangiare pesce crudo seguite una ventina
suo profilo ve lo linko qua sotto se ne
avete piacere noi naturalmente ci
continueremo a vedere durante
quest'estate e domenica con un nuovo
cucina buttata summer edition mi
raccomando se ne avete piacere iscriviti
a questo canale attivate le notifiche 9
10 un like se anche a voi scorso
qualcosa di assurdo e durante l'estate
ma soprattutto c'è nessun commento
facendoci sapere che cosa è successo
ciao o buon dio
[Musica]